bonsoir edouard husson merci d'être avec
nous ce soir sur arte france alors
emmanuel macron est le premier dirigeant
étranger à être invitée cette année dans
la capitale allemande en raison de la
crise est ce qu'on peut dire que c'est
un signe que le couple franco-allemand
se porte plutôt bien
bah écoutez je pense que ça fait partie
du folklore si vous voulez c'est un
petit peu de gesticulation moi je crois
si vous voulez au fond il ya il ya deux
tendances profondes
la première c'est le fait que les autres
pays européens supporte de moins en
moins le tandem franco allemand s'il
veut agir en solitaire la deuxième
tendance et qui effectivement lié à ce
qui s'est passé depuis un an
c'est bien évidemment le fait que le la
crise du coc vie de la nécessité du plan
de relance européen a mis un peu d'huile
dans les rouages du couple franco
allemand et en particulier a permis de
se rapprocher des objectifs de budget
européen qui étaient celles ceux
d'emmanuel maquereau en début de
quinquennat mais sur lesquelles
l'allemagne a fait la sourde oreille
avant la crise du coc vide c'était
important pour les deux chefs d'état de
se réunir vous parliez de difficultés
récentes c'était important de renouer le
lien en tout cas de montrer que le
couple ait des efforts c'est vous les
jeux je pense que l'allemagne
nana na pas y a de moins en moins besoin
de la france au sein de l'union
européenne
surtout depuis le départ delà de la
grande bretagne parce que l'allemagne en
fait et maintenant au centre et c'est la
première puissance économique en
revanche la france a besoin de
l'allemagne et en particulier parce que
étant toujours plus endettés c'est la
garantie que l'allemagne donnent à la
dette française indirectement soit en
acceptant le quantitative easing de la
bce soit en soutenant le plan de relance
qui fait que le différentiel entre les
taux d'intérêt français les taux
d'intérêt allemands ne s'accroît pas
trop donc je pense que la relation en
fait est profondément asymétrique madame
mère
elle n'a pas besoin de monsieur
maquereau en revanche monsieur macron a
beaucoup besoin de madame merkel ou du
successeur qui qui arrivera à berlin à
la chancellerie à l'automne on le disait
les deux chefs d'état se sont aussi
réunis pour préparer le conseil européen
qui aura lieu les 24 et 25 juin prochain
on a évoqué des dossiers assez assez
tendue notamment la turquie et la russie
quelles sont vraiment les les dossiers
selon vous qui occupe l'esprit de ce
couple franco allemand
il ya les dossiers que nous venons de
désigner c'est à dire le coc vide il en
a été pas mal question dans la dans la
conférence de presse il y a
effectivement il ya eu en filigrane la
question d'une journaliste allemande
pour savoir où on était le pacte de
stabilité si on reviendrait à des
exigences budgétaires après locaux vides
donc s'en vient d'en parler et puis il
ya eu effectivement la russie la turquie
moi ce qui m'a frappé dans les
déclarations des deux dirigeants tel
qu'on a pu les entendre pendant la
conférence de presse c'est le fait que
finalement la france et l'allemagne sont
très suivis vers des états unis donc
lorsque donald trump le disais je veux
je veux des relations entre nations et
le multilatéralisme ne m'intéresse pas
aller là la france et l'allemagne ont
été incapables d'agir ensemble c'était
une occasion historique unique pour une
vraie défense européenne et maintenant
que hayden dit on est tous amis le jeu
revient et qu'est ce qu'on fait on
essaye de s'entendre plus ou moins avec
la turquie parce que les états unis ne
veulent pas que nature qui sorte de
l'otan et puis sur la russie ont fait
comme on fait comme on peut
il faut préserver des relations
économiques tout en ne faisant pas de
peine aux américains qui eux mêmes
essaye de dialoguer avec la russie un
petit peu plus
etc etc donc si vous voulez ce qui m'a
frappé c'est que l'on n'a pas deux
acteurs autonomes d'une europe
européenne comme aurait dit le général
de gaulle on a des suiveurs de
l'administration américaine
vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure le coc
vide on va parler aussi de
sujet puisqu'ils ont une gueule à merkel
lors de sa conférence de presse s'est
dit étonné de voir des stades pleins
notamment pendant cette compétition de
football qui est l'euro des stades
pleins notamment en hongrie quelle est
la situation actuellement en allemagne
en allemagne si vous voulez le taux
d'incidence est maintenant extrêmement
bas et l'opinion est de plus en plus
agacés par le maintien d'une d'une
mesure contraignante et à tel point que
le candidat à la succession madame
merkel de son parti armin laschet tu as
appris a pris quelques distances avec
les mesures les plus strictes prônée par
madame merkel lorsque madame merkel
parle comme elle l'a fait l'an la
conférence de presse et en faisant la
leçon à d'autres pays qu'elle juge
imprudent elle n'est pas du tout en
phase avec l'opinion allemande
d'ailleurs on a on a assisté à une
baisse de sa popularité à nouveau ces
dernières semaines merci beaucoup
edouard husson d'avoir été avec nous ce
soir sur arte france rappelle que vous
êtes historien et spécialiste de
l'allemagne merci beaucoup